FOR ME LET US COME LOOKS OF
WATER UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MADAM SECRETARY WE'VE TURNED
OFF THE TELEVISION PLEASE
COULD SOMEONE TURN IT OFF
WELL HE SORT OF BOIL DOWN GO
TO THE USER YEAH WHILE HE'S
PRESENTING A BILL AND HE IS
A GARMENT HERE FLORA
GONZALEZ FLETCHER JONES SAWYER
PRESIDENT KALRA YOU MUST CARE
FLORA JUST HERE MCCORMACK'S
DOT WE HAVE A QUORUM OF WE
WILL HEAR FOR BILLS -- WE
WANT EVERYONE TO BE HEARD
BREVITY IS APPRECIATED AS
YOU KNOW THAT IT HAD BEFORE
SCHEDULE AND IT GETS MEMBERS
BACK TO THE FLOOR BUT THAT'S
SAID OF THE FIRST PRESENTER
WILL BE I AB TWO THIRTY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER O'DONNELL
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF AB TWO THIRTY
FIVE ESTABLISHES A THREE
PRONGED PROPERTY GROWING
STATE PRECIOUS PROGRAMS
STATE OF UTTAR PROGRAMS
FROM MY ON THE JOB TRAINING
WITH EDUCATION CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
COUNCIL ESTABLISHES
STANDARDS WHO WAIT HOURS
WORKING FOR ALL OF PRESSURE
PROGRAMS ACROSS CALIFORNIA
ORIGINALLY ESTABLISHED FOR
THE CONSTRUCTION AND BUILDING
THREES INDUSTRY SERIOUS
PRESSURE PROGRAMS HAVE
GROWN AND EXPANDED TO THE
RIGHT TRAINING AND A HOST OF
INDUSTRIES UNDER THIS BILL
THE CALIFORNIA APPRENTICESHIP
COUNCIL WILL CONTINUE TO
OVERSEE THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION AND FIREFIGHTING
PROGRAM IS THE VISION THAT
SHE BECAUSE THE DIVISION OF
APPRENTICESHIP STANDARDS WILL
IMPROVE IN A SELF DEFENSE
FOR ALL OTHER PHOTOGRAPHS
IN CONSULTATION WITH THE NEW
ADVISORY COMMITTEE -- AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S GOING TO HAVE A
PROGRAM AND WE ARE ALSO GOING
NOW FORMALIZE CREATION THREE
OF FRESHLY PROGRAMS PLEASE CALL
YOUR FIRST WITNESS ONE FROM
ONE OF THE BILLS WELL WITH ME
TODAY RISES UP STAYS ARGUES
THANK YOU ONE MINUTE SIR
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
COUNSEL I THINK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HEARING THIS BILL THE BILL
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME AND THIS
IS LIKE ALL MEN OF BASICALLY
WILL ALLOW A NONTRADITIONAL
INDUSTRY MISSION BASICALLY
THE HOUSE AND NOT HARM THE
EXISTING ADDRESS FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU YOU HAVE DIGITAL
WITNESSES -- THIS AWARENESS
IS TO ADD ON IN SUPPORT
THE CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU I FOR ME HAVE HOW
THANK YOU OFFERING CONSTRUCTION
EMPLOYERS THANK YOU DEFENSE
DISTRICT COUNCIL HIRE WORKERS
THANK YOU CAN I LOCAL ONE
THOUSAND THANK YOU RETIRED US
SO YOU CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
GREG FIREFIGHTERS IMPAIRMENT
LATELY THANK YOU TAUGHT LUCITE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
THANK YOU AND HELENA THOUSAND
JEWISH VOCATIONAL THANK YOU
FACILITY WITH FREE COUNSELLING
AND SUPPORT THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE WISHING THEY HAD ON IN
SUPPORT SEEING NONE IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION ANY OPPOSITION
TO THE BETTER GOING ONCE
TWICE THIRD SOLD -- IS THERE
A MOTION WE HAVE A MOTION
AND I WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE
THAT'S WHEN I WAS RICHARD
THANK YOU PLEASE CALL ROLE
OCEAN AS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SENATE AMENDMENTS OCCURRED
AND BERMAN THIS BILL DOESN'T
AYE GRECO AYE AYE IS THAT
NO THURMOND AYE FLORA FLORA
AYE CONTROL STRUCTURES I
THINK GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE
JONES SAWYER FIVE TWO THREE
KALRA AYE KALRA AYE LEAVE US
LEAVE US AYE STEINORTH AYE
STEINORTH AYE THE BILL IS
OUT CONGRATULATIONS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL NOT NEXT THAT
WE WILL HEAR AB ONE SIX FIVE
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER RUBIO
AND DEVELOPS SECOND THANK YOU
CAN SHARE MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
FOUR PROVIDES AN ATTRACTION
SEC THOUGH PRIVATELY GENERAL
VERY SPECIFIC CIRCUMSTANCES
UNDER THE BILL PARTNER WOULD
WAIT ONLY IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY IN ONLY FOUR HUNDRED
FOUR COVERED BY A COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING AGREEMENT THAT
RIGHTS FOR A GRIEVANCE
-- AGREEMENTS IN WRITING
ARBITRATION PROCEDURE UP
NOTHING IF IT SIXTY FIFTY FOUR
WHILE THAT THAT YOU CONTINUE
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME ALLOWING
PRIVATE CONTINUE GIVE TO GIVE
LOW WAGE AND I'M REPRESENTS OF
WORKERS WHO STAND ALONE THREE
FINGER EMPLOYERS THE ABILITY TO
FIGHT FOR WHAT THEY'RE ENTITLED
SHOW I HAVE ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL IS
SPECIFICALLY WRITTEN TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF AND LABOR CALLED
COVERED BY FIVE IT DOES NOT IN
ANY WAY RESTRICT THE ABILITY
TO TAKE LEGAL ACTION FOR
DISCRIMINATORY OR OTHER CLAIMS
OUTSIDE PODCAST I ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TO MAKE YOU ONE MINUTE
SIR HURT IF THEY KERN HEALTH
WHEN CONFERENCE FOR ITS MISSION
CRITICAL FREELY INTEGRITY
FOR COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENTS AND CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY WE THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE WISHING AT ON IN SUPPORT
GERMAN IS A SURVEY OF ANNOUNCED
A THANK YOU THOUGHT OF ONE SIDE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA POPULAR
THANK YOU THANKS FOR THE HELP
LET'S NOT GOVERNOR CONSTRUCTION
FOR SUSPICION THANK YOU SO VERY
ABOUT THEIR STEAK HOUSE WITH
SUPPORT THANK YOU KEEP THAT
DISTRICT COUNT THANK YOU TO
CRAM INTO NATIONAL THANK YOU OR
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE IS THERE ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU FOR YOUR THANK
YOU THIS BILL HAS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION WAS CALDERON
MOTION IS WITH RECOMMENDATIONS
SENATE AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED
IN THURMOND AYE THURMOND
AYE FLORA AYE FLORA AYE
GONZALEZ FLETCHER AYE GONZALEZ
FLETCHER AYE JONES SAWYER
AYE JONES SAWYER AYE KALRA
AYE CALLED AYE THREE MONTHS
I WAS STEINORTH FIVE THIS VET
BILLS OUT CONGRATULATIONS IS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON HERE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GIPSON WE WILL
MOVE PASS ITEM THREE AYE WHICH
I'LL PRESENT WILL GO TO ITEM
FOR AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE
SOME EVERY GIPSON PHILADELPHIA
BILLS MOVE A SECOND DATE IN THE
HAS A DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BELONG
IN PRISON SO THAT ROUGHLY
SIX OH FIVE THAT SEEKS TO
ASSURE REQUIRED TO MAKE --
SAFETY IS KEPT AS A PRIORITY
THANK YOU SIR ONE MINUTE IS
INTEREST OF BREVITY WORKING ON
SO WE HAVE PROVIDES NO THANK
YOU ANYONE WISHING TO ADD ON
IT SUPPORT MEMBERS FROM ALL
PARTS OF ENDEAVOR THROUGHOUT
THE MAKE YOU AS PART BELIEVE
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT
SEEING NONE ANY OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND WOULD LIKE CLOSER
THAT'S MY VOTE THANK YOU SAYS
DO PASS RECOMMENDATION PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL MOTION AS WITH
RECOMMENDATIONS AND AMENDMENTS
CURRENT AND THURMOND AYE
THURMOND AYE FLORA AYE FLORA
AYE GONZALEZ CLICK I SCIENCE
LECTURE I JONES SAWYER WOULD
VIEW GEORGE'S SPEECH OKAY AYE
I DID THEY DIE DIE
LAKE NONETHELESS
GOES OUT REGULATIONS
I THIS YEAR PRESENTING AB
TWENTY THREE THIRTY FOUR RIGHT
I'M PROUD OF THAT EIGHTY TWENTY
THREE THREE OR BACK TO THE
SENATE WITH PROVIDE SUPPORTING
IMPROVES PUBLIC ACCESS THE
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY
INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR I THINK ANY OTHER
WITNESSES THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN WAS MUCH HIGHER WITH
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION
PROJECT ALONG WITH CALIFORNIA
FIREFIGHTERS -- INITIALLY
THAT'S TWO VERY IMPORTANT
LEYVA WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY
ONE IF MEXICO SO THE MORE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGES EMPLOYERS
RECORD AND TO ADDRESS
CALIPHATES USUALLY
BEEN ADVISORY COMMITTEE
THEREFORE MORE LIKELY
WHEN INSTEAD OF SERVER
CURRENTLY ISRAEL IS FOR FOR
THE OTHER WAS A SPORT
FIREFIGHTERS
A WITNESSES OPPOSITION
CNN HAS FOR MEMBERS IT'S MORE
OF A STATEMENT BUT LATELY
IT'S PRIOR YEAR LAST PRESENT
HERE LAST ANOTHER CANADIAN OF
THE HAZARDS CARE AND I JUST
WANTED TO SAY WHAT A PLEASURE
SIR FUNDING HERE AS CHAIRMAN
OF THE LABOR COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE A LOT OF THE FELLOWS
THAT HEALTH REALLY SHOULD
ONES AND IF I'M UNLUCKY
FROM -- BELIEVERS
SHOWING YOUR METAL IN
HONOR CERVANTES
HE AND THE OTHER
AS THE VICE CHAIR
FOR A NEW LEGISLATOR COMING
THE VICE CHAIRMAN OF OF OF
AND FORTY COMMITTEE LIKE THIS
WORKING UNDER YOU AND WORKING
WITH YOUR STAFF HAS BEEN AN
INCREDIBLE EXPERIENCE CAN I
ABSOLUTELY APPRECIATE WORKING
WITH YOU GOOD THINGS WE'VE DONE
TOGETHER AS HUSBAND AN HONOR
TO WORK WITH YOU SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH YOU
EACH YEAR AND POLLS FACE OFF SO
NOW BECAUSE THAT WAS LIKE THAT
MOTION IS MADE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND INVENT SPEAKER THEN
THURMOND I THINK I'VE FLORA
I WOULDN'T I CONSULT AT
YOUR LIFE IN SOME FLETCHER
AYE SELECT RIGHT BY
CALLER KALRA THREE OF US AYE
AYE STONE AYE THE BILL IS
OUT THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
GREAT COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU TO MY VICE CHAIR
THINK IT'S WORKABLE LABOR
STAFFERS GIVE THEM AROUND
AND
YES YOU MAY MY LAST MEETING
THE FASTEST EVER LET
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED